trying to decide what to make your next
video on yeah got any ideas
not really it's getting warmer out and
I'm hungry so all I can think about are
s'mores huh your genius welcome to the
science asylum I Nick lucid summer is on
the horizon and that means campfires and
of course s'mores but maybe you don't
want to wait until summer lucky for you
there's an alternative to campfires it's
called the microwave oven while you're
making your delicious treats in the
comfort of your own home you might as
well do some science while you're at it
we're going to measure the speed of
light and this is how you do it you're
gonna need one pack of graham crackers
one bag of chocolate chips one bag of
marshmallows one microwave oven one
cutting board are plates one ruler maybe
a ceramic plate step 1 remove the
turntable and accessories step 1 a if
there are still spinning parts you'll
need to insert some glasses or a ceramic
plate as a stand step 2 find your
microwave safe cutting board or
microwave safe plate that will fit we'll
be using this as a tray for our s'mores
step 3
cover the tray and graham crackers step
4 make a grid of chocolate chips on top
of the graham crackers be sure to put
about half a centimeter between them so
heat doesn't flow from one to the other
step 5
place the full tray in the microwave
step 6
run the microwave on HIGH for about
eight to ten seconds step 7 check to see
that only some of the chocolate chips
are melty the melty ones will be shinier
than the others if no your microwave
sucks run it for another eight to ten
seconds if yes
remove the tray from the microwave step
eight the chocolate should be melted in
straight lines measure the distance from
one line to the next and convert to
meters twice that is the wavelength of
the light that cooks your food
step nine look on the back of the
microwave for the label record the
frequency and convert to Hertz no no
that's just the wall plug yeah the big
one
step 10 replace the turntable step 11
cover the chocolate and marshmallows
step 12 place the tray back in the
microwave step 13 run the microwave for
another five to eight seconds to smooth
out melty fun fact marshmallows expand
in the microwave step 14
remove the tray from the microwave step
15 press another layer of graham
crackers on top of your marshmallow
step fifteen a if you're crazy and you
hate melty things like me place your
s'mores in the freezer for 20 minutes
solidify set 16 the speed of light while
you enjoy your s'mores the speed of
light is wavelength times frequency so
in this case point 1 2 meters times 2.45
billion Hertz is 294 million meters per
second what we get is a bit shy of the
actual value but not bad only about 2%
error so do you plan on making s'mores
in the microwave let us know in the
comments along with your results for the
speed of light and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
mm yes mores hey hands off my s'mores